mahito
so you made
it mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place he Joy us I just hope he
stays
safe save me save me myo what exactly
are
you your mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lie but I have to see
I'm looking for
someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now angel
angel you and I aren't BS or Allies
kid don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready
you see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done a gray Heron once told me that all
gray herens are liars so is that the
truth or a lie a lie
truth have to be a lie
[Music]
too